Archbishop Monday will be such a
historic event on a scale possibly that
we've never seen before how do you feel
about your central role in that day
I feel very privileged to be there not
pleased to be there because
we would all prefer that this had not
happened but we're all going to miss and
grieve
for the queen
but
it's a huge privilege to be able to take
part in this focused on the family first
because this is a family
saying
goodbye at a funeral
to someone they loved do you get a sense
of of national mourning I know you've
been down to see the crowds queuing it
outside Westminster hall for example you
know is is there a shared experience
we're having here oh yes
yes yes I think it is a genuinely shared
experience it's an experience of grief
for many deep grief
but also mixed with an experience of
immense thankfulness
uh talking to people yesterday in the
queue and earlier in the week
listening to them they said oh I I'd say
why have you gone
I wanted to say thank you
and that was I found that deeply moving
he was the longest serving Prince of
Wales this country has ever seen is it
is it too much do you think to expect
somebody to to take on this role in
their later years no in his case no it
would be too much to expect most people
to take on this role at any age frankly
um
he is a man of very great intelligence
humility
thoughtfulness commitment to service who
has
not he hasn't just been sitting around
twiddling his thumbs waiting to take on
the role as we know his service to the
country and the Commonwealth around the
world has been huge in all kinds of
really applied ways
and he's been thinking about this role
for very very many years indeed a few
days ago on
Wednesday at the receiving at
Westminster Hall
there was
an almost tangible sense
of the of the roles the weight of the
roles settling on him
and him rising to gather that
and hold it as the queen did
such extraordinary tributes about her
majesty
her thoughtfulness and her kindness has
really stood out to the people I've
spoken to and you've had that experience
yourself haven't you from her yes very
much so I I the thing that there's been
all kinds of things but her capacity
to put one at onesies
I remember being at a a meal
with she asks a bishop in January every
year to go each Sunday to Sandringham
she used to do this and
preach Saturday evening quite often they
go for a barbecue
in January in North Norfolk in the um
in the woods in a cabin in the woods
and she has loads of hash guests and one
of them it's very relaxed
and there's no electricity in you all
day the table she does everyone knows
the table
and I was there thinking feeling this is
I'm going to wake up in a minute you
know this can't be real
and one of the house guests said to me
oh um Archbishop could you just put the
candlesticks on the table and light the
candles
and just something from my school days
you know when when you're new at a
school and people try and trick you
something for my school days just
bring a bell
and I went over to her and said man
would it be helpful if I put the
candlesticks on the table then the
candles and she's there was a little
twinkle in her eye because she knew what
was going on and she said I don't think
Prince Philip would like that at all
and she was they were just trying to get
me into trouble but
it was
it was so funny
and I've I've laughed about that ever
since and it was there was no malice
going on it was just a
playing around but she she was so
relaxed and fun and
yeah just a very very lovely human being
many people did say that her will meet
again messaged during covid got them
through the pandemic do you get the
sense at all that she's just leaving us
at just the just the wrong moment as we
head into this difficult winter which
many people are frightened about
um I think people are very frightened
about the future
and for many we mustn't forget you know
we've had 10 days of mourning but um
we've got the funeral tomorrow official
national morning ends I think
um day after tomorrow
but
that hasn't brought more money into
people's pockets
people are still going to food banks
during this time
struggling to work out
how to make the budget
last make the pay last as long as the
month
or the benefit last songs of the month
and people are frightened but
I am absolutely that the extraordinary
thing about the Royal Family
is that they knew that
and they are deeply aware of it
and yes there's going to be changes
and the next few months may be very
difficult many many people will be
but from the point of view of the head
of state there's been a seamless
transition
not to someone who's self-centered or
anything like that but as someone who's
sense of service and duty is the equal
of her late majesties
and with the immediate family round and
so though there's not going to be a gap
there there will be the hardship but
there's not going to be the gap
when was the last time you saw her it
was end of June early July
I can't quite remember the exact date
and I went along with um something to
give her actually a a cross of nails
like this these nails are a symbol of
the cathedral they fell from the roof of
the medieval Cathedral as it burned in
the great Blitz it's been used as a
symbol of reconciliation and peace
building around the world and she's had
such an influence on peacemaking and
police building and drawing people
together that I we gave her that gift
and I was privileged to give it to her
I came back and I said to my wife oh
we needn't worry I'm I'm not going to
have to
do a coronation
it'll be my successor who does that
she's so fit
and memory was so acute her observation
so perceptive
you got the benefit of 70 years of
accumulated wisdom in government
and in leadership and you know
not only her family but I think every
senior politician every
Archbishop will will will mess up you
sound like you will have to after that
hugely
you talked about the work the queen did
in peace and conciliation quite frankly
and we will watch all these people
arriving from around the world on Monday
and there is a sense even now that she's
unifying the globe in this don't you
think yes her conciliation and peace
building was not
the sort of Hands-On
way of doing it it was inspirational
and symbolic that made people look at
things a bit differently especially
within the Commonwealth
and work behind the scenes as we know
now from the time of the apartheid
regime in South Africa and
you know being very conscious of the
symbolic importance of what the British
government did at that time for example
um but she's going to unite more global
leaders
possibly than at any point in human
history
um and that is
perhaps a moment I hope and pray that
where they will
reflect on their own leadership
whatever their faith
and they'll be from all faiths and none
um
I hope and pray that they will reflect
on their own leadership and think
do I want my legacy
to be in the bank balance
of Earth
or in the words of Jesus who she
followed so Faithfully do I want to
store up treasure in heaven
and which she has done in her way of
service are you saying that they could
learn from her oh absolutely
um
absolutely I mean there are
extraordinary wonderful leaders coming
um
but I hope they find what they hear and
see and think about
a moment where they say to themselves
I would really like people to look on me
in the way that they look on her
we know they should be buried alongside
her late husband she'll be reunited with
her family her father her mother her
sister her tight knit family did she
really believe that she would see them
again
yes
how did she express that to you
not only to me but in her in that great
covid broadcast but in her Christmas
broadcasts as well
she was a deeply faithful and Faith
filled
under monstrative
quiet
Christian who trusted
in the faithfulness of God
in the words we often use
that she would and her family rest in
peace and rise in glory
it's at the heart of Christian faith
is she at peace now
yes
and should the nation take comfort from
that
I think the nation should take Hope from
that not just comfort
but hope for themselves it's a gift
that she knew that came from God
in whom she believed and trusted in whom
she served and who gave her the strength
to be what she was